[Musique]
regrettant de ne pouvoir exercer nos
fonctions dans des conditions dignes
tant pour nous que pour les justiciables
alors que la france compte toujours deux
fois moins de juges et de personnels de
greffe et quatre fois moins procureur
que la moyenne européenne et que nous
outils informatiques sont trop souvent
inadaptés ou obsolètes
nous dénonçons aussi les propos tenus ce
matin par le garde des sceaux sur france
inter qui a renvoyé la responsabilités
aux chefs de juridiction aux chefs de
cour et a considéré que c'était des
questions de management et
d'organisation
alors que nous savons tous que c'est une
question de moyens
là